il y a pas de fait divers sans
personnage fort people touche toutes les
CAD de la société donc y compris les
personnages de fait divers un fait
divher avec des people c'est une
histoire avec des personnes déjà connues
donc du coup on a la bonne histoire
écrite toute seule pas la peine de
l'écrire elle a déjà elle a déjà eu lieu
il y a plus qu'à la raconter et en plus
on a des bons personnages on ne supporte
les stars que parce qu'elle dérape si
une star était un vrai Dieu et était
parfait ça serait insupportable tout le
monde la détesterait il y a une demande
aujourd'hui des rédactions en chef dans
les journaux pour
couvrir le people mêlé au fit d'hiver
people ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
des gens bon les fait d'hivers c'est
toujours des histoires de gens après
dans ces faits d'hivers certains
personnages ressortent et ces gens-là
ont les héroïse entre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
guillemets
nous sommes dans les locaux de graadia
derniers né des journaux féminins haut
de gamme lancé en septembre 2009 cas
particulier graadia est aussi le seul
féminin à traiter de fit d'hivers l'idée
en est venue un jour au chef des infos
du magazine
moi personnellement j'ai envie de j'ai
envie de lire ça ça m'intéresse voilà ça
et puis ça plaît au lectrices tu vois ça
PL aux gens il y a une vraie une vraie
attente s tomber dans espèce de
populisme tu vois mais les gens ils ont
envie de lire des histoires et Leff
c'est le type de sujet sur lequel tu
peux le mieux raconter les histoires je
fait de croire que mais bon voilà c'est
rien n gagné qu'on a réussi à trouver le
traitement gradia pas trop trash pas
rentrer dans les détails des gens il y
il y a des faits un peu sordides qu'on
qu'on passe volontairement sous silence
parce qu'on n pas on n pas envie d'ê
dans le crapouteux
raconter on n pas envie de voir la scène
de CRIM comment ça s'est passer enfin
voilà on élague certains aspects de
l'histoire pour pouvoir être le plus
gradia possible plus chic possible chic
pour le féminin gradia branché pour le
magazine People voici aujourd'hui le
fait d'hiver est partout le fait d'hiver
fait fantasmer le fait d'hiver révulse
sous passionne le fait d'hivers à ses
stars victimes ou assassins le fait
d'ivers se Pise à longueur de journaux
d'émission de radio de magazine télé
50 Minutes Inside l'émission people de
TF1 traite autant de people que de fé
d'hiver une nouvelle revue sort au nom
sans ambiguïé serial people une
quinzaine d'émissions lui sont
consacrées à la télévision et une étude
de Lina rapporte qu'en 10 ans les faits
divers sont passés de 630 sujets dans
les JT des chaînes herziennes à 17 710
occupant aujourd'hui 10 % de chaque
journal
télévisé moi je crois que les chaînes de
télévision programme de plus en plus
parce que le public comme ça donc de la
part de la chaîne c'est pragmatique
elle voit bien que quand on met du fait
divver à l'antenne ça fait souvent une
une bonne audience voire une très bonne
audience en ce qui concerne fait entrer
l'accusé c'est une histoire qui
ressemble à un roman noir star in
contesté du genre avec son émission fait
entrer l'accusé sur France 2
christopheel a son idée sur les raisons
pour lesquelles le fait divers marche à
la télévision la plupart des
téléspectateurs viennent voir une
émission de fait divers un peu pour
vourisme et un peu pour s'interroger
eux-mêmes sur leur capacité à passer à
l'acte en telle et telle circonstance
parce que dans un coin de leur tête il y
a ça il y a cette idée que moi peut-être
je pourrais ou je ne pourrais pas ou
j'ai failli ou j'ai été tenté ou l'idée
m'a traversé l'esprit j'aime bien la
nature humaine je la trouve
formidablement intéressante je la
comprends pas complètement et euh je
trouve que dans le fit d'hiver on arrive
à une espèce d'état de paroxisme quoi
c'est-à-dire que on en
arrive une espèce de point de rupture
personne n'a l'air de lire des faits
divers personne n'achète un nouveau
détective et en même temps c'est
journaux qui se vendent bien et dans la
presse quotidienne c'est les pages qui
sont les plus lu pourquoi parce que on y
trouve les grandes affaires de la de
l'amour de la mort de la vie et que ça
nous met en contact direct avec les
grandes questions
[Musique]
d'existence
avril 2010 une escort girl fait trembler
le football français Zay 18 ans révèle
qu'elle a couché moyennant de l'argent
avec trois stars du ballon hexagonal
Karim Benzema syidney govu et surtout
Franck riéi dans le cas de ce dernier
l'affaire semble plus grave puisque'à
l'époque des fait en 2009 za était
mineur ou comment une partie de jambes
en l'air tarifé tour au fait d'hiver
sans aucune volonté de nuire za est
gagnante sur toute la ligne elle
n'incrimine pas ribéi et en profite pour
faire parler d'elle d'anciennes vidéos
un peu chaudes ressortent sur internet
un compte Twitter un blog au nom de za
dear et 116 compte facebook plus ou
moins crédiible une créature People est
née si za devient tout d'un coup un peu
au centre des préoccupations c'est parce
que aussi elle-même euh a une une
certaine comment dire un tempérament
people qui qui qui éclate au grand
jour on le voit sur la couverture de
Paris Match on le voit à sa façon à sa
façon de poser à sa façon de parler on
sent bien que cette fille est assez à
l'aise avec la notoriété et et donc elle
a effectivement un potentiel people
extraordinaire véritable consécration
pour une jeune femme inconnue un mois
auparavant le 28 avril Paris Match lui
accorde six pages à sorti d'un interview
Paris Match faisant la une avec une
escort girl il fallait oser laffire Zaya
et la couverture de match a suscité de
la part de lecteurs des réactions qui
ont certaines étaient positives
certaines étaient négatives certains
lecteurs ont été choqués qu'on puisse
avoir une prostituée en couverture du
journal même si j'ai expliqué que depuis
l'affaire profouo en 63 en passant par
le Christine dev Jeancourt la
scandaleuse n'avait jamais été un sujet
tabou dans match alors évidemment là
encore match les autres en parlent les
match le
Christine devier Joncour du nom de cette
maîtresse de Roland Duma ministre de
miteran impliquée dans l'affaire Elf et
qui s'était autoproclamer la putin de la
République et profouo du nom d'un
ministre britannique compromis dans un
scandale avec une colgir dans
l'Angleterre des années 60 de femmes
sulfureuses qui ont fait les beaux jours
de Paris Match si le paparazi William
ABENAIM connaît bien le monde des people
c'est aussi un passionné de fait d'iver
pour lui avec l'affaire za on se situe
vraiment au croisement des deux l'oire
de Ribéry avec la prostituée et cetera
là vous allez avoir une couve dans match
avec si pages avec avec cette femme qui
a été qui a été interviewé par match
c'est quoi ça c'est bien un fiter PIP ah
oui oui oui je pense que oui c'est une
tendance qui qui qui se fait de plus en
plus Bertrand villgas a créé l'agence
the wi spécialisée dans la veille
audiovisuelle en France et à l'étranger
pour lui si Z n'a rien à se reprocher
Fran riberry a étrangement réussi à
passer entre les gouttes za très bien
elle fait son business elle elle
exploite l'affaire comme elle peut
puisque ça a toujours été son si regarde
sa biographie apparemment ça a toujours
été son but d'être une célébrité les
médias se jettent sur elle aussi
uniquement parce que l'autre le celui
qui pourrait être coupable qui aurait
peut-être enfreint la loi ne communique
pas du tout on peut imaginer peut-être
dans un autre pays un type comme riéi on
lui aurait conseillé de s'exprimer de de
dire quelque quelque chose peut-être que
les médias français sont pas assez
violents peut-être qu'ils n'ont pas
assez traqué à la sortie de chez lui ils
nont peut-être pas foutu une pression
tellement insupportable qu' aurait dû
qu' aurait qui serait expliqué donc ça
veut dire qu'on est dans un système qui
protège certaines qui épargne
relativement certaines personnalité
finalement mise en examen après le
Mondial 2010 riéi aura à répondre de sa
relation clandestine l'affaire za n'est
peut-être pas
terminée c'est pas une histoire qui
passionne la France c'est il y a une
curiosité sur le personnage de za donc
voilà mais la curiosité s'arrête assez
rapidement il y a des dans les grands
fits d'hiver la curiosité sur les
personnages sur les protagonistes ne
s'arrêtent pas on dire je mettrai pas du
tout la fire dans dans la catégorie des
camp fivers d' c'est un fivers sans
lendemain c'est end of the story après
la première histoire c'est entendu le
mini scandale entre l'escort girl za et
le joueur du Bayern à la frontière du
fait divver sulfureux et de la
pipolisation accélérée n'est peut-être
pas l'affaire du siècle mais à quoi
reconnaît-on qu'un fait divhiver a une
dimension people ou non que les
protagonistes soient ou ne soient pas
[Musique]
connus selon Laurence Lacour tout a
commencé avec l'affaire villemain en
1984 à l'époque jeune journaliste elle
fut pendant 4 ans l'envoyé spécial
d'eurin sur ce fait d'hiver à nul autre
pareil un fait d'hiver dont elle dit
qu'il a brisé sa carrière et même son
envie de poursuivre son
métier j'ai eu le temps de voir quand
même les dégâts qu'on a laissé derrière
nous et bon moi je suis désolé mais ça
me satisfait pas de savoir qu'il y a
derrière nous un homme qui est mort un
autre qui est devenu assassin alors que
vraiment intrinsèquement parlant il
était destiné à tous àf ça et une femme
totalement broyée sur l'hôtel non pas de
la justice ni de la vérité mais de tout
un tas d'autres paramètres donc voilà
moi j'ai pas envie j'avais pas envie
d'être de continuer être dans un système
qui laissait les gens sur le carreau
donc je suis parti et ben c'est moi qui
qui d'une certaine manière brisé ma
carrière l'affaire villemain commence en
octobre
1984 avec l'assassinat du petit grégoryi
4 ans retrouvé mort noyé dans la volne
une rivière des vauges je me souviens
encore du du soir de bouclage on a pris
la mort d'un d'un petit garçon sur les
trouvé mort dans la Vologne avec les
mains et les pieds liés et euh le
premier dès le premier boulash ça été un
grand sujet dans le journal 5 six pages
je crois je m'en souviens et et ensuite
ça a été le grand feuilleton qui a
démarré qui a qui a enflammé toute la
rédaction parce qu'évidemment c'était
l'histoire traversait des
rebondissements incroyables et tout d'un
coup la France s'est mis s'est mis à se
passionner pour se fait Diver la suite
est connue persuadé de la culpabilité de
son cousin Bernard Laroche Jean-Marie
Vilmain labas d'un coup de fusil puis
sur la foi de témoignage douteux
Christine villmain est inculpée si elle
finira par bénéficier d'un nonlieu elle
restera pendant de longs mois au centre
de l'affaire comme une possible mère
infanticide couverture de journaux
instruction baclé et insinuation en peu
de temps Christine V devient une
célébrité malgré
elle comment vous personnellement vous
réagissez au fait qu'on puisse vous
soupçonner pas trop bien quand même
c'est quand Mme mon petit
com finalement c'est quand même vous la
victime dans cetteairezim qu'on ESS un
de le trouble dans l'enquêtece que le
petit plus là plus rien je sais pas ce
que ça m'aurait rapporté d'avoir fait
ça elle ne peut pas faire un pas hors de
chez elle même lorsqu'elle rend visite à
son mari en prison elle est traquée sans
relâche grégoryi est passé au second
plan et d'ailleurs après on en parlait
plus beaucoup c'était plus la
fascination qu'exerçait cette jeune
femme tout était cristallisé sur elle
autour d'elle comment elle était
habillée pourquoi elle faisait CCI
pourquoi elle faisait ça elle c'était
l'incarnation à la fois du
mystère à la fois j'ai du mal à le dire
parce que 26 ans après c'est tellement
horrible mais du monstre à la fois de
l'ange pour d'autres enfin voilà donc
c'était plus Grégory c'était vilemain et
Vilmain c'était elle et au-delà de la
vétarisation de Christine Vilmain c'est
toute une communauté qui se retrouve
sous le feux de la rampe c'est un feu
d'iver qui est un véritable cas d'école
je pense qu'on vit aujourd'hui de plus
en plus dans une société fermée chaque
policier doit être pixellisé chaque
témoin doit être pixellisé il faut c'est
c'est la Rene de l'anonymat le fait
d'hiver d'affire Grégori c'est tout le
monde est est à visage découvert c'est
peut-être terrible quand on quand on le
revisite 20 ans après mais en tous les
cas tout le monde apparaît à visage
découvert il y a des photos partout et
match va être un témoin direct du
fitiver c'est-à-dire que une semaine
après la mort du petit grégoryi ou je
crois que c'est même 15 jours ou 15
jours on réunit jeanquer réunit le clan
villemain autour d'une table et cette
photo là un an après sera encore pour
pour pour les policiers une source
d'information savoir comment les comment
est-ce qu' le le suspect le criminel le
corbeau est-il sur cette photo donc il y
a eu il y a eu cette cette incroyable
c'est ce fait div reste un cas d'école
unique parce que les journalistes
étaient immergés dedans on pouvait pas
sortir le matin sans voir sur le kiosque
cette affaire faire la une ce qui est
quand même pas toutes les affaires c'est
quand même pas de l'ordre toutes les
affaires par ailleurs il y a eu à un
certain moment une traque totale de de
la mer de l'enfant et on avait le le
sentiment que petit à petit l'opinion
publique se faisait
par finalement t tous ces articles sur
cette trague de la mer Paris Match
consacrera 14 couvertures à Christine
Vilmain en 2 ans elle prendra même le
risque de l'impopularité en se laissant
photographier à la maternité avec son
deuxème enfant un an après la mort de
greégory si elle se prête à cet exercice
moyen en finance c'est aussi pour payer
ses
avocats je me souviens d'une d'une
interview qui avait été faite justement
de de Christine villmain dans dans ces
années là enfin dans cette époque là où
quelqu'un lui avait dit vous vous rendez
compte que vous avez un statut de
vedette aujourd'hui et que vous êtes
très critiqué pour ça et elle avait dit
mais on croirait que les gens sont
envieux du malheur qui nous
arrive elle avait vraiment ce sentiment
c'est vrai qu'ils étaient pris dans un
engrenage dont il n'arrivait pas à
sortir à une certaine époque
c'est-à-dire la presse qui accuse il
faut répondre il faut répondre une
certaine manière il faut trouver de
l'argent enfin c'était un système
totalement délirant évidemment ils
étaient très critiqués pour ça parce que
ça n'allait pas avec le deuil ça
n'allait pas avec l'humilité ça n'allait
pas avec l'innocence donc rien nallait
dans cette histoire de toute façon rien
n'allait jamais la défense de Christine
et Jean-Marie Vilmain durera 9 ans elle
coûtera jusqu'à 250000 € que leurs
avocats se chargeront de récolter en
négociant des séances
photos
épiphénomène de la médiatisation
outrancière qui a entouré l'affaire le
grand photographe de mode helmou Newton
sera dépêché sur les lieux par Paris
Match il fait poser les protagonistes de
l'affire tel des mannequins d'un jour et
un soir moment de grâce un corbeau vient
s'échouer sur la fenêtre de son hôtel
comme un écho aux nombreuses lettres
anonymes dont le dossier est
rempli mais surtout libération on verra
Marguerite Duras faire un reportage sur
Christine villemain son article à charge
pour la mère de greégory alors même
qu'elle ne l'a pas rencontré restera
célèbre pour son titre sublime forcément
sublime
aujourd'hui plus de 25 ans après les
faits Christine et Jean-Marie Vilmain
ont retrouvé le calme de l'anonymat avec
leurs trois enfants ils ont quitté l'est
de la France pour s'installer en région
parisienne toute la dérive sur l'affaire
sur l'affaire villemain a totalement
changé de métier et aujourd'hui on lutte
effectivement pour revenir et faire
comprendre qu'on n'est pas que des
[Musique]
chiens pipolisation excessive
interprétation fantasmatique de fait
dramatique vénétarisation d'une
criminelle qui cherchait tout sauf la
lumière des sunlights tel est l'affaire
Florence r avec son amant et complice
audri Mopin un soir d'octobre
1994 elle part braquer les policiers de
la préfourrière de Pantin en scène
saint-enis en s'enfuyant ils prennent un
taxi en otage l'Odyssée des dehors la
loi se poursuit place de la Nation le
taxi percute une voiture de police le
chauffeur est tué ainsi que deux
policiers par audre Maupin la fin de
l'Escapade meurtriè aura lieu au bois de
Vincen dans lequel un autre policier est
abattu et Audrey Mopin lui-même touché
il succombera ses blessures le lendemain
bilan du carnage cinq morts et plusieurs
blessés un carnage dans lequel Florence
Ry n'aura qu'un rôle de complice mais
qu'elle devra assumer seul une certaine
presse l'appellera d'ailleurs la tueuse
de
flic la mort des quatre policiers est
absolument effroyable ils sont morts sur
le trottoir dans les bras des passants
match montre montre les les photos
d'ailleurs et euh pourquoi Florence re
arrive en couverture de match parce
qu'il y a un mystère parce que c'est un
personnage incroyable parce qu'on on on
narrive pas à comprendre comment cette
cette fille qui a un regard presque qui
a une adure presque chérubain qu'est-ce
qui a pu se passer et à ce moment-là ça
devient un fait diviver national ça
devient la Une de match et et d'ailleurs
ça ça nous a c'est pas une une qui a
c'est une une qui a été problématique
pour le journal parce que les lecteurs
ne comprenaient pas pourquoi nous
aviononss mis une criminelle en Une de
match
une criminelle qui pourtant ce soir-là
n'aura tiré aucune balle
mortelle patricia touranchot est
spécialiste du fait d'hiver à Libération
elle a couvert de nombreuses affaires
comme cell du gang des postiche ou
l'affaire allèigre elle s'est tout
particulièrement passionné pour
l'affaire
florenceeray cette fille a
suscité une une passion incroyable dans
les banlieux certains on sorti des
t-shirts à l' figie de de Florence Ray
elle est devenue légérie de
révolutionnaires de gens qui voulaient
mettre le système par terre [__] en
l'air le monde comme elle disait avec
audre Mopin et cette fille avant d'aller
de monter au braquage avec son amoureux
c'était taillé les cheveux à la
sauvageone comme ça avec des ciseaux et
tout un peu un peu toute guingois et et
et elle avait un air un peu un peu buté
et donc cette photo a fait le le le tour
du pays elle a reçu des milliers de
lettres qu'elle a pas ouvertes elle a
demandé à son avocat de les de les
cramer moi j'ai reçu des des cassettes
de la musique des cadeaux pour Florence
Ray c'était un
délire les hommages se multiplient de
façon presque imperceptible Claude
Chabrol dans la cérémonie fait un clin
d'œil à l'affaire en glissant dans les
mains d'Isabelle huper un journal avec
Florence en couverture c'était pour
faire comprendre au spectateurs le
principe de la folie à 2 c'est qui qui
est une chose extrêmement importante
dans dans le fuiver c'est que le la la
folie à de c'est c'est c'est des actes
qu'accomplissent des individus mais
quand ils sont par deux s'ils étaient
seuls ils ne les accompliraient pas et
et et Florence c'était exactement ça et
et j'ai voulu montrer que c'était ce
genre de ce genre de folie qui qui qui
qui allait amener les deux deux F
excusez-moi de vous déranger vous savez
je suis jeanne Marchal la postière de
saintcouon effectivement la cérémonie se
termine RAM par un massacre collectif
perpétré par les personnages quiincarne
Isabelle huper et Sandrine
Bonner mais il n'y a pas que le cinéma
qui s'inspire de l'affaire roman bande
dessiné pièce de théâtre ou musicien
comme les angloaxons de The Kills ou MC
solar rendent hommage au couple r
Mopin mais pour son avocate la réalité
du personnage Florence Ray était à 100
lieu de cette marchandisation
soudaine j'ai connu Florence Ray à peu
près 2 mois après les faits et
évidemment j'avais l'image d'une espèce
de de passionnariat Don la presse tait
fait l'cho et donc j'avais des idées
assez préconçues en en venant la voir et
puis donc je suis arrivée à fleurogis et
puis j'ai j'ai découvert une petite
chose toute fragile toute timide et et
c'est vrai que j'étais très surprise par
que c'était pas du tout l'image que que
j'attendais enfin à laquelle je
m'attendais bah finalement elle est pas
elle est pas si extraordinaire que ça
cette cette jeune fille et d'ailleurs
elle s'est plainte à un moment donné de
de de qu'on lui donne tant d'importance
elle ne se rendait même pas compte la
veille du procès qu'on allait parler
d'elle moi je je j'étais allé voir ses
avocat pour avoir des éléments sur ce
qu'elle faisait en prison faire un
portrait d'elle à publié le jour de
l'ouverture de son procè d'assise à
Paris et elle disait mais je veux pas
qu'on parle de moi elle se rendait même
pas compte de l'intérêt médiatique et
qu'elle suscitait en France
effectivement elle avait honte elle
avait honte de de d'être célèbre pour
des faits comme ça elle aurait préféré
devenir célèbre pour des choses quand
même beaucoup plus avoables suite à
l'épopée meurtrière de Florence et de
son amant une affiche du film
d'oliverstone tné avait été retrouvé
dans le squat qu'ils occupaient
l'histoire d'un couple de
de médiatisation il n'en faudra pas plus
à certains journalistes pour comparer le
couple qui a fait un carton sanglant
place de la Nation et celui du film
[Musique]
n'it rien à voir avec personnage de
tuerné mais je pense que bon c'est vrai
que le film tuerné à l'époque dépeignait
peut-être une certaine jeunesse et
c'était facile de faire coller une jeune
fille avec un jeune homme euh qui avait
donc commis des faits euh tels qu'on les
connaît et euh et puis te faire coller
avec peut-être une image de cinéma ou
voilà c'est c'est c'est le côté un petit
peu négatif si j'ose dire de la
presse j'ai vraiment eu le sentiment
qu'en arrivant au procès les jeux
étaient presque faits en fait
euh il y avait des articles dans tous
les sens
euh mais allant toujours dans le même
sens euh c'est vrai qu'on on arrivait
avec Henry Leclerc à devoir défendre une
espèce de de filles horribles une tueuse
quoi c'était pas le cas entre tueurs
sansfinillois et anarchiste romantique
Florence Ray et Audrey Mopin auront
alimenté les spéculations pendant de
longs mois au procès les ressorts
éventuellement romanesque de leur Caval
n'auront pas droit de citer et Florence
ser et copra de 20 ans de prison enfermé
pendant 15 ans elle est sortie en 2009
c'est pas du tout une affaire romantique
simplement parce que les gens voient un
crime commis ou des une série de crimes
commis par des jeunes gens un couple et
cetera qui qui partent comme ça
oui ça peut évoquer chez certains une
certaine folie amoureuse enfin une
certaine certain vagabondage romantique
mais en fait non pas du tout donc ça
c'est vraiment une déformation une
réinterprétation de la réalité bah par
les médias par les écrivains par par les
gens qui ont fait un crime romantique
qu'est-ce qu'un crime romantique hein
moi j'ai rarement vu de crime
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
romantique romantique l'histoire d'amour
tragique entre Bertrand Kanta et Marie
trintigan l' pourtant été jusqu'au
moment fatal nous sommes à Vilnius en
Lituanie fin juillet 2003 le couple qui
se vousoue une passion réciproque s'est
retrouvé sur le tournage de Collette que
tourne la mère de Marie Nadine
Trintignan pour France 2 un soir où le
couple se dispute à son hôtel Bertran
Kanta frappe violemment Marie qui
succomberra quelques jours plus tard à
ses blessures en une poignée de secondes
une histoire d'amour fou a viré au
cauchemar le fait divhivers le plus P de
la décennie va défrayer la chronique
Frédéric vezard et Stéphane boucher
travaillait à l'époque pour le Parisien
ils furent parmi les premiers
journalistes à se rendre sur les lieux
quand j'étais dans l'avion en partance
pour Vilnus on a j'avais assez peu
d'information mais on avait l'essentiel
c'est-à-dire qu'il y avait eu une
dispute que elle était quasi perdu et
que lui était en garde à vue et je me
suis dit dans l'avion qui m'amenait pour
Vilus que c'était quand même une affaire
avec des des ingrédients hors du commun
mais que je pense que j'aurais pas
d'autres affaair de ce niveau-là avec
une telle portée émotionnelle à traiter
dans toute une carrière je
pense c'est assez unique de voir tout
d'un coup que le que le meurtrier et la
victime sont sont sont deux stars ça
c'est une situation un petit peu unique
et tout d'un coup arrivent deux clans
d'un côté vous avez vous avez le clan
trintigan mais clan trintigan qui est un
clan rallonge puisque Marie a eu
plusieurs a eu plus plusieurs hommes
dans sa vie vous avez les parents qui
sont aussi Nadine et et Jean-Louis
Trintignan qui sont des des grands
personnages français de l'autre côté
vous avez le clan le clan Kanta avec les
les musicien de de Noir Désir mais l'une
des raisons pour laquelle le fait
d'hiver va grandir dans le journal c'est
parce qu'il y a ces deux personnages
très forts qui sont des gens que tout le
monde connaît et puis parce qu'il y a
parce qu'il y a aussi cette l'absurdité
de de la situation un antagonisme qui va
se poursuivre pendant le procès un
procès à l'issue duquel Bertrand Kanta
sera condamné à 8 ans de prison Kanta
était à ce moment là un homme
complètement détruit voilà enfin l'image
de Kanta arrivant dans le box avec son
pull trop grand moi j'avais l'occasion
de le voir sur scène de c un mec
flamboyant avec une énergie
extraordinaire charisme incroyable on se
retrouvéit face un espèce de gamme main
engoncé dans son pull complètement
shooté sur sur les médicaments c'était
assez assez étonnant il y avait une une
haine perceptible dans cette salle quoi
qui était qui était très prenante donc
c'était difficile de pas de de de pas
rentrer là-dedans c'était un procès
assez étrange assez théâtral quand on
est journaliste notamment dans la presse
populaire une affaire avec des
ingrédients comme ça c'est sûr que
évidemment on saute dessus après elle
nous touche tous que ça soit journaliste
pas journaliste tout simple citoyen
donc il a fallu essayer de de être de
travailler en toute objectivité de pas
aller vers la passion aussi parce qu'on
a forcément un avis sur l'histoire mais
ça a été je pense une expérience
journalistique assez intéressante et
puis ça a mis tout le monde dans la Bou
que ça soit euh les journalistes de
médias de spectacle de fait divers voilà
de société donc ça ça a touché tout le
monde en fait mais je pense que dans
l'ensemble la presse a été malgré les le
côté passionnel de l'affaire a été
plutôt digne dans cette affaire quoi qu'
pu en dire certains protagonistes
que s'est-il passé à l'hôtel domina ce
soir-là l'affaire occupera toute la
presse pendant l'été 2003 et en tout
premier lieu les journaux
people il y a un mystère qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé qu'est-ce qu'il a eu dans la
tête de Bertrand Kanta est-ce qu' est-ce
que Marie tratigan a reçu autant de
coups qu'on le dit donc il y a un
feuilleton il y a des questionnements
qui se qui se développent sur des des
sujets qui sont ultra connus et ultra
populaires donc quelque part
effectivement c'est une c'est une
affaire idéale si je puis dire pour la
presse people en dérapant dans la
rubrique fait divhiver Bertrand Kanta et
sa victime Marie Trintignan deviennent
alors l'espace d'une surmédiatisation
galopante de simples people dont
l'opinion publique va s'emparer c'est
vrai dans cette affaire vous avez raison
de dire qu'ils étaient certainement sur
un statut de star qui sont descendus
entre guillemets du côté du people et ça
ça s'explique en fait par plusieurs
raisons d'abord parce que ce sont deux
personnes connues déjà et donc ça en
fait la press people préfère toujours
avoir deux personnes connues alors après
il va y avoir plusieurs choses qui vont
faire buzzer le people en fait et faire
que le récit people continue en général
c'est les vacances évidemment les
enfants les disputes les séparations les
retrouvailles et toutes ces choseslà
tous ces récits en fait le poids le
travail mais surtout les amours dans
dans le cas du meurtre évidemment c'est
c'est horrible à dire mais la mort et ce
qui d'abord ce qui ce qui rapproche
également du public parce que ça nous
arrive tous un jour et que on a on se
pose tous des question là-dessus donc
c'est malheureusement un sujet tentant
et un sujet plaisant et c'est hélas pour
les médias le sujet qui marche le
mieux dernier épisode d'un feuilleton
qui mélange tragédie et people le
suicide en janvier 2010 de la mère des
deux enfants de Bertran Kanta Christina
[Applaudissements]
Radi loin de la tragédie quant à
trintigan certains people pointent à la
rubrique fait d'hiver parfois pour des
broutis montés en épingle par les
tabloïdes excès de vitesse alcool au
volant comportement provocateur ces
people semblent franchir les limites
uniquement pour que l'on parle d'eux
elles ont pour nom Lince LAN Paris
Hilton Britney Spears ou encore Naomi
Campbell et leurs écarts de conduite
font plus souvent parler que leur
performance il suffit de conduire comme
linelohan bourrer ou de de de d'insulter
comme Naomi Combell son personnel de
maison et on voilà comme ça on se fait
remarquer plus moins volontairement et
on est toujours dans les dans les médias
mais parfois la pipolisation a ses
limites et suscite l'agressivité comme
ici avec Britney Spears s'acharnant
contre une voiture de
paparazzi la célébrité c'est quelque
chose de très particulier qui vous fait
ne plus toucher terre vous avez plus de
plus de limite et n'ayant plus de limite
personnelles vous ne voyez plus les
limites collectives qui sont celles
fixées par la loi du coup effectivement
il n'est pas il est presque naturel que
les people dérapent et si nos propres
journaux people sont Tru fait des phases
que de ces Starlet c'est parce qu'il n'y
a aucun risque éditorial c'est super
pratique de de faire des couvertures sur
britne Spears ou Paris Hilton ou des
personnalités américaines parce qu'ell
attaquent pas la presse française
contrairement au français donc on
préférera toujours faire une couverture
un peu limite sur un people américain
c'est beaucoup plus facile ça c'est
vraiment la raison la plus simple mais
la plus véridique et juridique en fait
parce que maintenant les les titres
veulent vraiment pas avoir le minimum de
procès et d'autre part des personnes
comme Amy Winehouse ou Paris Hilton et
Britney Spears bien sûr alimentent leur
vie voilà tout le temps de de petites
choses comme ça la prison pour Paris
hton britne Spears qui se r rase les
cheveux devant 30 Paparadis elle-même en
fait elle crée son propre récit il a
rien à faire que juste à la suivre et et
donc en effet c'est du petit fait
divhiver entre guillemets mais ça marche
très bien et ça vend et ça vend très
très bien Annique dubier est sociologue
à l'Université de Genève elle est l'une
des rares universitaires à avoir
travaillé sur les relations entre fit
d'hiver et people le fait d'iver à
l'intérieur des nouvelles people a
toujours existé ce qui me paraît plus
nouveau et et et
relativement contemporain c'est ce que
nous on a appelé le phénomène des
trajectoires trashes c'est-à-dire que on
on insiste sur un certain nombre de
célébrités qui connaissent le contraire
d'une success story après avoir gravi
toutes les marches de la célébrité du
succès euh ces célébrités là
dégringolent et redescendent une à une
les marches du succès dans une espèce de
unsuccess Story et la presse en rapporte
chacune des étapes l'une après l'autre
on a vu apparaître ce genre de
trajectoire en particulier chez les
jeunes femmes ces dernières années que
ce soit Britney Spears Amy wiinehouse
lindcey LAN ou Samina Sée dans le champ
francophone qui sont donc ces célébrités
qu'on montre comme perdant tout ce
qu'elles avaient gagné au fond ces stars
viennent incarner les incertitudes du
monde contemporain et là je dirais qu'il
y a euh fait diversification du people
plutôt dans ce sens-là c'est qu'on voit
de plus en plus apparaître ces histoires
à long terme de la l'Ascension et de la
chute d'une célébrité grandeur et
décadence d'une célébrité c'est en
résumé ce qui est arrivé au cinéaste
Roman planski retenu en Suisse pendant
10 mois dans l'attente d'une possible
extradition aux États-Unis inculpé de
viol sur
mineur une affaire sur laquelle était
revenue en 2008 le documentaire wanted
[Musique]
roman polsk rattrapé quelque part par la
justice des années après avec la
question mon Dieu est-ce que il va faire
de la prison est-ce qu'il va être
relaxé tout ça ça ça crée c'est le
registre de la peur et ce registrel ce
levier là est important dans la presse
people des ordes de photographes et de
caméraman devant la résidence où était
assigné roman polansski une image qui
soulevait alors une question impliqué
dans un fait d'hiver un people est-il au
regard de la loi un individu comme un
autre c'est le problème du PIPOL qui
achète quelque chose he dans le commerce
il y a des commerçants qui vent lui
faire un cadeau parce qu'il des PIPOL
est connu pensant qu'il y aura de la pub
derrière ou je sais pas quoi puis y a
d'autres qui vont le lui mettre un un
prix plus cher parce qu'il est supposé
avoir plus gent que les autres ben la
justice doit pas se comporter comme ça
la justice doit être équitable pour tout
le monde quelle que soit la qualité des
gens jusqu'à sa libération inattendue en
juillet 2010 Roman Polanski a reçu le
soutien d'une grande partie du monde
culturel et artistique mais pas sûr que
la réaction quasi unanime du gothta du
showbiz est servi la cause du
cinéaste qui est certain c'est que le le
fait divers d'origine a été renforcé et
c'est là que le people intervient par
tout toute une série d'interventions qui
sans doute ont plus desservi roman
Polonski qu'ils ne l'ont favorisé
notamment de d'un certain nombre de de
célébrités qui sont venus à son secours
en évoquant des des arguments très
rapidement comme ça et qui au fond a
fonctionné comme défense de quelqu'un
qui fait partie du même monde et et je
pense que c'est en partie ça qui a
déclenché la la cont-réaction et qui a
déclenché la violence des attaques
[Musique]
inverse on reste en Suisse pour se
pencher sur un cas très particulier
celui de l'assassinat du banquier Edward
Stern par sa maîtresse Cécile brossa en
février 2005 les ingrédients sont
sulfureux un financier international
retrouvé mort tué de quatre balles le
corps gainé d'une combinaison en latex
un déguisement sadomazo la fin d'une
liaison tumultueuse comme il sera dit au
procès dans laquelle Cécile Brossard
aurait été la proie d'un homme humiliant
harcelant et cruel l'accusé ne sera
condamné qu'à 8 ans de
prison une affaire qui inspiré à
l'écrivain régisse Geoffrey un livre
sévère et voilà comment un homme d'affa
uniquement connu des cénacles de la
finance devient une fois mort unoss
possible people dont on décortique les
pratiques sexuelles
laffirechne est intéressante parce que
la dimension People est peut-être moins
évidente à l'origine c'est effectivement
une personnalité qui appartenait à une
certaine élite dont on avait parlé même
si on en avait pas parlé comme on parle
des people habituellement mais dont on a
commencé à parler au moment de de sa
mort et et des suites de sa mort en
reprenant un certain nombre d'éléments
qui sont typiques du traitement people
la description d'un monde enviable d'un
monde privilégié qui est tout à coup
rattrapé par le sordide par par la
transgression on a des transgression
morale des transgressions légales bref
par le fait divers dans sa nature
transgressive absolue au
[Musique]
fond le fait que ces histoires prennent
en fait c'est que on fait accéder à un
grand très grand public des des récits
des récits autour des gens riches des
personnes qui ne sont pas de notre
milieu et donc c'est une sorte de
satisfaction aussi qu'on essaie de
convoquer chez les chez les gens qui
regardent ça qui lisent ça c'est tiens
tu vois eux aussi ont des problèmes eux
aussi tu vois ça finit toujours mal ces
histoires là donc coup c'est vraiment
rassurer une population rassurer le
grand public en essayant de de dévoiler
des choses auxquelles on a'urait pas
accès et donc ces personnes-là sont plus
intéressantes que d'autres du moins pour
les médias parce que il y aurait c'est
comme s'il y avait quelque chose a caché
parce qu'ils ont de
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'argent en novembre 2004 disparaissait
la fille de l'acteur Roland girud
Géraldine girud et sa compagne
katielerbier les deux corps seront
retrouvés calcinés dans le jardin de
Jean-Pierre trbert garde chasse
emprisonné mis en examen pour le double
meurtre trber s'évade en septembre 2009
de la prison d'oxer nargue la police
pendant 2 mois avant d'être repris il se
suicidera en février 2010 3 mois avant
son procès
dans cette affaire ce qui frappe c'est
le glissement de notoriété qui va
s'opérer entre Roland Girot et trber
justement comme si le people n'était pas
forcément celui que l'on croit stéphane
mkaa est fait diversier il s'est
passionné pour l'affaire depuis le début
pour VSD puis pour Paris Match cette
affaire a-t-elle été médiatisée au
départ parce que c'est la fille de
Roland girud qui disparaît
oui il est certain qu'un homicide un
double homicide de deux femmes
lesbiennes euh dans toute autre région
de France et dont le les parents sont
inconnus aurait pu monter comme on dit
en National c'est-à-dire passer vraiment
des pages locales à à quelques JT et
cetera mais n'aurait jamais dépassé ça
c'est évidemment parce que Roland girud
est le père d'une des victimes qu'autant
de
journalistes se sont intéressés à
l'affaire au départ oui si au tout début
de l'affaire la personnalité de Roland
GIR occupe tout l'espace de ce fait
d'hiver particulièrement sordide petit à
petit l'enquête prend le dessus de
l'importance ou de la personnalité de la
notoriété de Roland girud on s'en est
débarrassé pour s'intéresser à laffire
elle-même et au fur et à mesure non plus
se dire il s'agit là du
crime d'un crime concernant une
personnalité célèbre mais au contraire
il s'agit d'un mystère qui va bien
au-delà de la personnalité d'une
victimes c'est au cœur de ce mystère que
tous les regards se tournent vers
l'inquiétant Jean-Pierre trbert dont
tout porte à croire qu'il est le
meurtrier même si l'enquête piétinera
longtemps très vite écroué il se fait
oublier dans l'attente de son procès
avant coup de théâtre de s'évader en
septembre 2009 la situation bascule
c'est trbert qui devient la célébrité de
l'affaire ce qui s'est passé avec
Jean-Pierre trbert c'est un peu étonnant
parce que il a plutôt plutôt bien
négocié quelque part par son son
repositionnement médiatique parce qu'il
est apparu pas très longtemps mais comme
quelqu'un de finalement plutôt
sympathique et peut-être peut-être en
tout cas quelqu'un d'innocent aux yeux
de aux yeux du grand public il a occuper
quelque part aussi tout le terrain que
ne voulait pas occuper Roland girud qui
au contraire dans cette histoire a
toujours été très très pudique preuve
supplémentaire de la trait qu' exerce
treber sa folle cavale inspire toute une
série de sketch de plus ou moins bon
goût sur le net Jean-Pierre trbert on te
croit tu ne connaissais pas ces deux
femmes enterré dans ton jardin j'ai vu
Jean-Pierre trbert c'est un beau gosse
plutôt
where
jeanierre jeanierre il cour il cour le
Jean-Pierre en ce m de petite crotte
avec la police au derrière c'est
Jean-Pierre trbert Jean-Pierre trbert
Jean-Pierre Jean-Pierre [__] suis-moi
Jeanpierre je te balancerai pas
Jean-Pierre je te jure si on réussi à le
choper tu tu fais une interview de
Jeanpierre trber tu refiles à Christophe
il a moyen de se faire un max de poignon
fais-moi confiance je te jure parmi les
Indis que se treber durant sa cavale des
lettres pour le journal Marianne et
d'autres que Stéphane ma va intercepter
et faire publier dans Paris Match le
présumé innocent entretient sa propre
petite
mythologie quand on publie dans match
les lettres de Jean-Pierre trebert on
fait de l'information brute euh on
raconte en tout cas on on laisse on
laisse un un fugitif s'exprimer et euh
ça va très loin ça va tellement loin que
je finis par retrouver
trber en guignol de l'info et euh c'est
super violent ça fait un mois et demi
qu'il échappe à 300 gendarmes d'élite
ouais mais tu sais la forêt vietnamienne
est tellement dense que tu peux
retrouver personne non mais il est pas
au Vietnam il est en samarne dans la
forêt de bonbon près de Mulin dans cette
forêt il échappe à 300 hommes ou oui je
connais ce genre d'individu c'est un
cauchemar fort comme un pufle agile
comme un singe il se déplace qu'en roul
Boulé et il a une vision nocturne hors
du commun non trber il est très maigre
un peu âgé et il louche il y a pas eu de
concurrence entre girud d'un côté trber
de l'autre lequel sera le plus
ça c'est du discours quand on n'est pas
dans l'affaire je comprends qu'on se dit
ça n'importe qui terrasse d'un bist se
raconter te rends compte il est encore
plus connu que l'acteur maintenant
toujours est-il que Jean-Pierre trbert
aura réussi presque malgré lui à accédé
à un statut d'inculpé d'exception auéolé
de mystère et de souffre treber lui il a
réussi à devenir un personnage
médiatique en s'adressant au médias en
jouant avec les médias et donc
finalement là on est moins dans le
people que dans le médiatisé tout
simpleement simplement et trber c'est un
personnage qui a habité selon les
personnes qui parlaient de lui qui était
à la fois un Robin des Bois un
héros le plus pourri enfin vraiment on a
tout dit sur lui et en fait ça faisait
vendre ça marchait bien et en plus il
racontait sa vie dans Paris Match et il
parlait pas au moindre des médias je
veux dire donc il a lui-même en fait a
réussi à gérer cette image média et
c'est vrai que ça a créé du récit
jusqu'à la fin quoi jusqu'à la fin
c'est-à-dire jusqu'à son suicide qui
laisse la famille GIR ainsi que la
justice sur un point d'interrogation qui
était et qu' réellement fait Jean-Pierre
trbert aucun magazine People ne pourra
jamais nous le
[Musique]
révéler et puis au-delà de tous ces
crimes qui font l'actualité et mettent
leur protagoniste en lumière existe une
catégorie de meurtriers qui sans être
vraiment des people exercent une
fascination très particulière sur
l'opinion publ il s'agit des tueurs en
série ils ont pour nom Thierry Polin 18
meurtres Francis Holm 6 Guy George 7
Patrice Allègre 5 Émile Louis 7 ou
encore Michel fournirit neuf
meurtres nous sommes au centre
psychiatrique du bois de Bondi dans la
région parisienne c'est là qu'officie le
docteur Daniel zaguri les tueurs en
série le connait bien il a en effet été
expert psychiatre au procès de gu George
Patrice allèigre et Michel Fourniret et
il se défend des idées reçues sur le
sujet on leur
attribue des pouvoirs et des qualités
euh qu'ils n'ont pas euh et ce faisant
on prend un risque parce que on
s'identifie euh à la toutepuissance
imaginaire qui est la la l'heure au
moment du passage à l'AE criminel on les
croit toujours plus intelligents qu'ils
ne sont donc euh on leur attribue des
désirs des plaisirs des jouissances des
motivations euh qui ne sont pas vraiment
euh celles qui les font aller euh sur le
chemin du crime et
euh c'est un petit peu ce ce si vous
voulez cette cette démitification qui
moi m'a m' m'a intéressé une
démitification à laquelle s'emploie
depuis plus de 30 ans Stéphane Bourgouin
spécialiste des tures en série auquel il
a consacré de nombreux ouvrages selon
lui la pipolisation du serial killer
n'existe souvent que dans la tête du
tueur lui-même avec les tueurs en série
on est confronté à un paradoxe
euh ils n'ont aucune envie de se faire
arrêter contrairement à ce que peuvent
dire un certain nombre de psychiatres
mais en même temps il rêvent d'acquérir
cette notoriété d'être reconnu pour leur
œuvr entre guillemets criminels parce
qu'ils sont ce désir de toute puissance
de devenir l'égal de Dieu d'être connu
comme les plus forts parce que dans leur
vie quotidienne ce sont des êtres
totalement médiocres totalement négatif
qui n'ont jamais rien construit de
positif dans leur existence que la
plupart de les tueurs en série la
plupart cherche aussi à on un ego
surdimensionné et cherche à faire parler
d'eux donc c'est un peu aussi le et la
contrepartie c'est qu'à un moment il B
ils se font choper bon voilà certains le
cherchent même et à ce moment-là ils
devinent sélèvres et à ce moment-là on
fout de leur vie ils savent et pour les
people il y a aussi des people euh qui
joue ce jeu-là qui qui s'expose
volontairement ou qui qui raconent des
ce qui se qui laisse raconter des
histoires autour d'eux parce que ça les
flat et parce que ça leur permet
d'exister mais c'est vrai qu'on a
starifé le même les tuur en série
récemment moi j'ai fait un documentaire
sur fourniré il y a il y a pas très
longtemps c'est vrai que c'était c'est
devenu une sorte de people du crime
quelque part par la durée avec dans
laquelle il a il a tué son mode
opératoire le fait qu'il tu avec sa
femme enfin c'est un personnage hornor
mais qui est devenu un personnage public
pédophile violeur et assassin Michel
fournirait probablement le pire de tous
les tueurs en série surnommé l'ogre des
ardenes il a commis ses forfaits de
Belgique en France pendant plus de 15
ans
ouiama benim au cours d'une planque l'a
photographié pour Paris Match pendant
une garde à vue l'occasion de troquer
son costume de paparazzi people pour une
tenue camouflage de
fitersier voilà c'est cette photo là qui
av fait le
l'apparue quand je l'ai vu en face de
moi bah pour moi c'est cétait je veux
dire c'était ma cible je veux dire
c'était ma cible c'était le mec que je
de shoter voilà notre mission nous
c'était c'était d'avoir sa tronche à
fournir donc moi moi j'ai appuyé sur le
bouton je su [__] ça y est je l'ai il
va il va on va le publier ce [__] là
j'étais content de
l'avoir fascination répulsion le tueur
en série inspire des sentiments
contradictoires mais la pipolisation
prend une tournure inquiétante lorsque
ces prédateurs suscite de singulières
passions reconnu coupable de pédophilie
de viol et d'assassinat dans les années
90 le Belge Marc Durou est de
cela face à du trou qui tue plus
plusieurs jeunes filles et des enfants
on se dit que c'est le cri celui que va
tout le monde va le rejeter il reçoit
des lettres d'amour en prison
aujourd'hui de même que par exemple en
Belgique il y a il y a 2 ans il y a un
jeune garçon qui a été tué des enfants
dans une dans une crèche donc des jeunes
enfants de de 3 ans il reçoit maintenant
des lettres d'admiratrices il y a des
sites Web qui lui sont consacrés de
personnes qui trouvent que c'est un
geste de défi de révolte etera c'est un
peu incompréhensible mais c'est une
force de fascination qui existe des
seril Killers stepphan Bourgouin en a
interviewé plus de 70 parmi eux Gérard
Cheffer accusé du meurtre de 34 femmes
alors qu'il exerçait la profession de
policier c'est un tueur qui cumulait
absolument toutes les perversités
possibles et même inimaginables il a par
la suite publié des textes de fiction
qui
racontent ses propres fantasmes
nécrophiles sous forme de nouvelles et
qui ont été publiés euh et ensuite vendu
people W W this is so terrible is so
disgusting do can I
more W this is really weird you know
people are writing and they like it they
want more and they're saying this is
horrible it's like one girl wrote she
says I was so scared I couldn't sleep
for 3 days do you have another book
coming out I you know
dans ces livres Cheffer parlait aussi
d'autres sérial killers comme t Bundy
ouol notamment pour en détailler
quelques pratiques très très
morbides killed people cut them and ate
them and PR barbecue sauce his own
recipe and put the barbeue
sa sauce barbecue d'tiol en vente la
recette en détail sur Internet rien
d'étonnant à cela il existe tout un
marketing autour des tuurs en séries aux
États-Unis alors ceci par
exemple c'est des cartes comme par
exemple en France on a les Panini avec
les
footballeurs là il y a les trading cards
puisque c'est c'est fait pour des
échanges où vous avez les tueurs en
série les plus célèbres edgin qui a
inspiré psychose massacre tronçonneuse
et le personnage de Buffalo bille dans
le silence des
agneaux ici vous avez un t-shirt d'un
goût douteux qui est à l'igie de John
Wassy un tueur en série gay qui a tué 33
adolescents et qui a été exécuté sur la
chaise électrique dans
l'îinois un article que l'on peut
trouver sur le net au même titre que
divers vêtements et accessoires t-shirt
à l'effigie de Charles menson qui s'est
rendu célèbre pour avoir fait tuer
Sharon Tate la femme de roman polansski
en
1969 t-shirt mais aussi sac de plage mug
t d'oreiller ou encore le pire de tous
bodies et bavoir en coton bio pour les
bébés le fait d'hiver fait vendre c'est
indéniable même les victimes peuvent en
profiter c'est le cas de Natacha
campouche 22 ans cette autrichienne
enlevée à l'âge de 10 ans et séquestrée
pendant 8 ans un temps elle a animé un
talk showow à la tlévision et sa vie
sera bientôt portée à l'écran Kate
Winslet a été contacté pour jouer son
rôle autre films à venir en France cette
fois-ci présumé coupable avec Philippe
toreton sur Alain MCO Luissier impliqué
dans l'affaire d'Out TR ou encore Omar
matué de roche dim avec Sami boagilla
dans la peau
d'omaradad et puis preuve s'il en était
encore besoin de laattrait pour le fait
d'hiver le succès de l'exposition Crime
et Châtiment exploration du regard des
artistes sur le mal au fil des siècles
présenté de mars à juin 2010 au musée
d'orset à Paris dans la file d'attente
une dame nous confirmer l'intérêt du
public pour le sujet on est attiré par
le
crime c'est peut-être m ça c'est vrai
que ça fascine un petit peu le cri
non la fascination pour le crime a donc
traversé le temps aujourd'hui elle
s'expose au musée la pipolisation ultime
du fait d'hiver décidément entrer dans
les
[Musique]
murs